another course maybe i don't know why
this game is more satisfying than golf
with your friends but it is
oh wait what not too fast don't go too
fast
i went fast
oh weird oh this is gonna not be good
for brain
my brain's smoothing by the second gang
oh
well bogeyed all right hey yeah i move
on
oh
let's not say ruffle our roofies anymore
that's not good go ahead and call it
some other
oh [ __ ] i got this i got this okay i
believe in you
oh okay okay my turn go for it nailed it
nailed it nailed it oh no killing it
killing it
wrinkly brain
[Music]
wait i know what to do about this oh
wait i see it yeah you see it you see
the path
you see the path yeah i have a problem
because weight
i saw the path oh what
what the hell wade
all right he's lost the ability to talk
oh oh he made it
there you go sorry i just had to take a
pissed off moment there to
suck my root my root my room
[ __ ] my room [ __ ] your roof i was trying
to say rubles
where did it go oh the brain it's
enormous hey
what's up losers but
[Music]
oh no there's a secret what do you mean
there's a secret there's a laser the
laser is the secret
that's pretty good that's pretty good
you all nailed it i'm the
greatest and the greatest most growl
nailed it yeah
she is so wrinkled it is [ __ ] insane
well done boys good
i'm glad you liked your song man but
that was a little much
what do you mean you hit him with the
well done boys the moment you're
finished singing
[Music]
good song well done boys we need to
start a band
we'll call it wayne and his thoughts
okay man youtube could be my thoughts
dude i would love to be your thought
dude i want to be a thought
dude i want oh for you no that's really
unfortunate i want to see
wade's thought lineup i want to see no
you don't want
to see his thought lineup it's a
different oh god even way they're not
adventure
wait you gotta you gotta take a gander
or what's going on with that oh before
you go
fired way done firing it well
oh no okay i see the path
the path is true i see the past yes wait
what happened and how
i am a genius hey mark hello oh you were
so
close you were so close
that seems really unfortunate for me i
solved it bob bob look i didn't solve it
at all we got the same score
good job wait a minute wait before you
oh my god
did you make you just get through there
what i'm going for
oh my god don't jump
tricky at all don't jump it's fine
this is fine how did all of
god i'm a god are we sure that wrinkle
brain is smart is that is that actually
smarter the more wrinkles is that true
yeah wrinkle is good smooth bad smooth
bad okay ghouls and fallout
always call you smooth skin which is bad
right right yeah yeah brains gotta be
like the opposite
yeah okay i'm trying to increase my
wrinkles per minute here i'm really
really wrankling i cannot
see i cannot see my yeah i i was just in
a scenario where i could not see either
that was really much
too difficult the heart really it takes
your ability to understand what the hell
is happening doesn't it yep sure do sure
do
blinkist that's what i thought grimy
mime i was tricked
oh look at this whoa what
where was that hey look the hole's right
there
there we go these portals are how was
that how did funerals
yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait whoa
what the hell just happened
how did he get the same score as us i
guess our brains are smoother than we
thought mark
maybe they really are maybe where's the
flag
what the and why am i behind the box i'm
not sure
about this i found it mark
i did the right thing where is it i go
through the tunnel at the end of it
there's a flag hey buddy going
gotta go pretty fast just punch me in oh
come on man i'm never going to
come wow that was actually really close
to being helpful
i tried i did try thanks bud that is
wade's mo really close to being helpful
i figured the first game i [ __ ] it so
hard
oh no what is that about
oh my god harry
oh i actually am a harry who was it
jerry
you're a you're a jerry i called my
french uncle and uncle said to me
what did i say uncle i called my friend
jungle
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think that
oh
looks like all of us are very
wrinkle-brained yeah wait wait it's not
oh no wait it's here okay i'm here good
job everybody
what do you mean what's a hole what's a
hole where's the hole watch out for the
hole what hole
it's a good hole no you want to get in
the hole
that's not a good oh it is a good hole
it is a good oh i thought
it was very good oh my god okay you're
right it was look how good that hole it
was a pretty good hole
we've all been in some holes but never
like that hole yeah
hey mark hello a little spicy on mine
but okay
okay i think i got this one in the bag
guys if i get a zero on the next two
i'll make par again
oh no i'm going oh wow
oh i saved myself because i'm smart no
why did i jump bye mark yes this is
where we make a backpack
this is where we earn our gravy i'm
alive
come on you idiots wait just hold on
jump
quick jump oh daddy why did i jump
why did i yes good work mark you
tricked me you only need to get like 12
more strokes and i'll catch up
so be careful yeah wait for it jump
no jumps for me all right this is it
gang whoa
whoa whoa oh
what happened to me what has happened
i'm in heaven
this is where i go this was not enough
i don't think that's right oh poopies oh
wow
did you make it in wid i did i eagled
nice
[Music]
what was that oh no oh
you're off center that's unfortunate oh
no oh no
oh no oh no oh no
oh i see what's happening there we go oh
that solve my problem
i think that's all my problem what if i
what if i
whoa all right okay let's just take my
time
this
there we go already line it up oh darn
it apparently 14 is where they cut you
off
hey i made par i'm very happy how the
hell did you do that and i got stuck
in the abyss of not doing it i am so
good
dude my brain is so cervical well
i hope not man i really hope not
more oh i should have jumped watch out
oh god hey oh no have you ever had
a 90s casual realization no
i should have jumped yeah i don't think
this is going to be definitely just jump
on this one
all right where's the where's where's
eyes wait where's tell me twice
watch this secret i'm the best i'm the
best
i am the best
oh where are we what is what no oh no
oh boy oh yeah okay
no unnecessary ah i didn't need to do it
why would you go
i don't
thank you both of you for helping me out
of that situation
appreciate it what did you do
yeah that was your fault what do you
mean i took you you took me out
that was your fault still you weren't
still enough oh titties oh no
oh no oh mark what have you done mark
this is called carpe diem
oh
wait no stop guys this is not fun
wait what do you do what are you
supposed to do fishy about this hole
mark yes
keep going in the hole mark that'll get
it
you go over this side
sorry mark i didn't mean to be so coy
there
wait what are you waiting for me to go
are you waiting for you okay
everyone's waiting on you what's i got
smart do you got straps
i got stress man oh the wrinkliest brain
in the world
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh no
oh my god oh my god oh my god mark if
you jump
from a high distance you will jump
higher oh my god oh my god oh
oh there you go dude on the grid
i can feel it smoothing oh guys there's
a sword over there
mark you remember how funny it was when
you died to the sword
am right damn right with
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh mark that's not that's not the way
buddy
you can you can do it man no yeah if you
bounce off those
umbrellas you might umbrella
umbrella hello hey hey
wait you got the same as me shut up you
got the exact same
yeah but i did it in style no you didn't
watch this
[Music]
are those shurikens it's fine
just don't let them don't let them touch
no i'm they're
just called shurikens oh yeah but they
were going to kill one of us
get out of my way
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is a weird thing to start a
story with
but manny and i have been watching uh
america's next top model we're watching
cycle 20. there's a bit
where there's a guy who's introduced as
a character
and he has like a name a name tag and he
just walks on screen wearing nothing but
a speedo and he's like a
like a chubby really hairy dude anyway
my takeaway is that there's a type of
modeling that basically revolves around
being incredibly hairy
and i feel like i'd be really good at it
i'm not like
like big beard like overtly hairy but
like oh
[ __ ] total volume of hair is pretty
good
i got i got a good amount it's all over
it's evenly spread you know what about
someone like me that has
very little hair you would be called
smooth model okay
wait you know smooth model why am i
called a smooth model because you're
like the kendall down there okay cool
down there well i mean no
i'm not do you have no
there's i just want to say there's stuff
going on down there have you seen a
doctor about it
no bad stuff i get on the zoom call with
my doc and i try to take my pants off
too shocked about the doctor inquisition
is there something
[Music]
why didn't you hey mark why are you
bumping me hey bob
i thought i did that to you and i was
like i'm going in the
no yes diamond why did you jump yeah
because i was slowing down
look it gives doesn't it give a little
more momentum oh that worked
is there uphill
okay you guys see the path oh
i see the biggest brain play wow
you got your spaghett in my hole is that
a good hole or a bat hole bob
we'll see it's okay it's not a good one
oh my god no
why here is this good good hole no
oh go up top okay
that's not bad that's pretty good that's
all right
enough nice nice balance dude i'm fine
here we go there we go here we go is it
really not going to give it to you
[Laughter]
i hate it oh interesting
[Applause]
how long it gave you a lot more time
than it seemed like it was gonna yeah
well it doesn't really go back down very
quickly you just have to not go
please on the line i'm on the line
you get out of my way that's what you
get well i've never heard you so
disappointed in mark's failure before
wade
oh wow are these not at
45 degree angles is this is this like a
prank
where these aren't 45 degrees it's an
optical illusion actually
it's just this is it i hate you right
[ __ ] you
i hate you
[Laughter]
don't you dare [ __ ]
you guys took a lot of swings on that
one [ __ ]
yeah okay uh-huh get out of my way i
hope this is good
i hope it's good i don't think that's
good oh hell yeah look at me being a
genius no
no no what okay okay
little [ __ ] boy laugh when things go
well yeah right
i was just really happy for me i'm
pretty sure that was straight up fuckboy
left
damn girl whoa oh
no oh no
no no wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i'm
not jump on the fish
bounce off the f this is really sad you
hate to see this
you do it's not nice
fine go in the hole look at those ones
hmm
one's a bb ignore my other number but
look at those ones
look who's got the wrinkly brain now oh
is it me
we all have on days and off days this is
an off day
it doesn't feel very good it doesn't we
can be friends we can be friends
join yourself oh my god here i go i'm
good
more flesh didn't work out at all why
why why why why oh
that's like upper class like just like
it's actually a specific character from
family guy that i'm totally ripping off
but yes oh is that a bottom jaw
underbite
[Music]
go call me tiger weeds i'm not gonna
call you that this looks like um the
island from runescape
that you go to for the pirate wait wait
first pirate mission
did you ever play runescape are we
supposed to go in the cannon
oh i think so touch the cannon it's
magic
whoo it is it is magic
oh my good god oh my god
i got par hello seagull
i got par what
wait did you just go directly in the
hole i sure did
god what the hell did you do
oh well i was gonna jump there but last
minute i decided what the farce that
would be
birdie i got to birdie poop you are
i got a birdie bob did you get par
i don't like that no did you get power
wait why are you jumping you full-on
monkeyed out there man oh this is you
[ __ ] to your own self
there's a trap and i'm going for it i'm
going for it you're going for it i'm
going for it
what it's actually not a trap but also
you can just get a hole-in-one
i'm in the tube oh what
i'm just gonna take the hole this time
you dick
you dick hey wait
i'm not done i'll it'll come back all
right see ya oh
wait wait
i got the birdie you wish you were a
pretty birdie
oh interesting there's cheese oh my god
cheese
oh there is cheese yeah there's cheese
dude birds
birds love cheese dude for them i love
cheese
i didn't think it was that gouda for him
oh my god
wait do we got to touch a cannon is this
what we have to do we have to touch
again it looks like yeah
i went out the window don't go in left
cannon left cannon bad
oh hey hey buddy how's it going oh my
god
yeah let's go inside together hey mark
how's your touch
oh yeah definitely jump a bunch that'll
help
i didn't jump i didn't jump no wouldn't
you have jumped
because i don't know
wait bob did you thread the hoop i
absolutely
hey i was complimenting you i was
complimenting you
i know and i was complimenting you
douche douche bags are very hard
items no i didn't try to hit you he just
aimed at the hole
way more savage than i would have
expected i didn't uh
nailed it i'm the best i'm
really you're not gonna give that to me
hey mark oh god i pulled a mark i'm
stuck in the tube
it was gonna give me a hole in one but
then it did oh no oh wow
oh yeah oh no oh
oh yeah brother
oh wow go away
you want to help me okay i got i hate
you
okay we're all equivalent
we're all equally good at it all equal
the hell are we even supposed to go the
seagulls
hi bud okay i got you really pressed up
against the wall here i missed you
what ha ha i guess i was a little
overzealous
wait this is our chance this is our
chance to take back what's ours
hey there we go yes jump
more mark stop constantly oh i have
calculated jumps i
uh i'm really smarting about these jumps
that's fast okay we're gonna not have oh
there's a little
you didn't tell me there was a gap guys
you you were not prepared
but he was just so good at not [ __ ]
it oh i [ __ ] it that's right
well i'll just do this i got it
i got pogba looks like golf with your
friends
silly this is clearly golf around yeah
can't you tell the difference well
there's a golf around is that the name
of it
golf around that's what it's called you
know you golf around
[ __ ] you know you go off here you golf
there you golf around
you know you can go around with your
friend no
no complete coincidence [ __ ] me in the
[ __ ] ball sack
that's impossible oh
yeah calm down nailed it where are we
shooting i'm with you neck and neck just
me and bob and no one else
where are we shooting i hope it's oh did
you guys think about that
yeah someone's talking to the little
prematurely yeah
here we go i put my hands in
the balls really slow down all right
yes i'm the best i'm the greatest ever
in the history of forever
oh if you want to hit me i would never
have forgotten
you
ah uh okay this is interesting why
didn't you stop
dead there your mark just go ahead let's
see what happens to you yeah mark come
on
flush my pipes here i go
oh
all right i'm an [ __ ]
nailed it whoops i'm the greatest oh yes
oh yes oh yes oh yes oh
this feels so good oh it feels good baby
oh it feels good oh it feels good
oh my god it feels good it feels good
it feels good
you stole that from me finished
i think that we all win prize money no
no no no no no no no okay well yeah
then i guess yeah well yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yes oh no oh my god mark that was almost
the the
wrinkliest spring thing i've ever almost
okay well keep watching
[Music]
that well this is uh did someone turn
the bounce up on this
this is i think hey thanks wade
hey man the steampunk land is just
really bouncy yeah that makes sense wow
marquez
oh my god i hate both of you let's have
a good gaming experience for once
that's how i got down there as well
oh you all suck well
no mark so we all suck yeah you get in
there
no i got in there
you know you should jump it's real fun
in here when you jump i can't jump
really you're moving
i will not jump look at me be a dead
center
i hate
[Laughter]
[Music]
i hate god
damn it all of my skill has gone away
[Applause]
oh my god do we gotta go on the block
over here
[Music]
oh
oh my god and wade gets the same number
as me how
how skill precision amazing
maybe we're brothers
i'm gonna do it too ah almost no
yes what did you think was gonna happen
i saw a slope behind me here the thing
is happening
right now fool foolish excellent work
everyone fool
where are we going here
[Music]
i kind of want to go in the big hole
there yeah go for it
why oh didn't get to be in the big hole
no come back
[Music]
i'm sorry are you eating your success
right now i
you guys better hurry up i'm i'm going
to catch up
i'm going to win it i'm so centered
i'm
i was dead center as well you're kind of
worth it
just really didn't work the same for you
which is just oh yes it happens
i hate everything where am i
oh so sorry if it's where am i wouldn't
it be and you're so
sorry get in there mark yeah
don't talk to me don't talk to me don't
talk to me
i'm gonna be talking to mom what was
that you
watch out time is not on your side you
hit me
you hit me
you you almost hit me again
you almost hit me nobody ruined my
perfectly good too much speed is not
good
in that one hey wait hey
[Music]
i could see the bottom of your ball dude
do you
like it don't don't hit it don't touch
me don't touch that's the benefit on
this one
it definitely is because watch this yeah
it would be it would be and it is
yes all right we're all in we're all in
we're all in baby
look at me being literally look at me
literally dead center look at you look
at me
literally dead
look being first doesn't matter in fact
in some circles it's bad get out of my
way
get out of my way get out of my way
everyone is in my way i don't know what
you're saying
you dick you thank you dick
oh you did can you give me a little
boost
no never come on man oh my god
wait oh my god oh my god where are we
going wait what oh my god
that really grinds your gears uh whoops
uh don't go
not too much speed there how did i fall
out oh my [ __ ] seat belt wasn't on
you're there sorry i got really oh man
that doesn't work
what the hell yeah i know
look when you do unisonis you get some
perks from father what is that
ah you can't make that jump by the way
you cannot make that jump
yes you can ah oh my god
oh it made it back out look at me guys
how does it feel to still be
[Music]
all even it's all tied up yeah it's
really close
i'm the greatest
what is your who you better be yourself
and not me
myself because you suck so bad but yeah
you do good luck not to be able to see a
goddamn thing
you're right i could not it's
sweet
oh wow it really is where are we
going oh right here baby yep
oh no crap okay yeah oh my god
thank god is it just any of them
i'm going back right baby never mind yes
i
am garfield garnuckle what's his name
yeah that's it garfield garnuckle oh i
see
this is fun
look how good i am oh i think i just
bumped you out mark
[Music]
we all know
what eats wait no mr gear
listen she wants to you want to bring me
with them but i don't want to go oh my
god
oh my god oh my god do you hear the
collapse of man
it sounds like
hey that's what the gear tried to do to
me and i was like no thank you and he's
like okay i'll get the next guy
remember when i was winning maps you
guys remember that when i was winning
man
that wasn't the way what the hell yeah i
don't recommend doing that
yeah i'm gonna follow mark mark seems to
have the stretch yeah i got the straps
going in the holes this is the trick hey
mark we ended up in the same place buddy
yeah we sure did buddy what happened to
me yeah
that was a little early oh oh yes i made
it
oh my god i got pinched i got it i got
take me down oh okay
hello i'm building up speed and momentum
i didn't actually pay close attention to
how much my lead is i might be totally
giving this away right now
yeah i'm gonna catch you man i'm getting
i got you man
oh i used to be good i used to be good i
used to be good guys i used to be i'm
just gonna
go over here oh my gosh you can do it
man
you can do it like the little [ __ ]
idiot
he gave you every opportunity mark look
look even at my score it's not like i
had huge numbers all the time
just consistently bad just consistently
bad
i might not have won but i feel like
can we that's a positive can we take
that away consistency
consistency consistent dude yeah thank
you
all right that's all the maps we're done
here we're leaving